what happens if elaine maxwell commits
suicide then what are you gonna are you
doing
who's that who's that that's the lady
who just got arrested because that was
epstein's right-hand woman who
was your first name again what happened
to like susan
well i don't know where what happened
jennifer
um so uh so if she if she
ends up dead but prob look if she does
it's probably going to be
going to be an overdose and it'll just
be an overdose she's probably a drug
addict
she's she's locked up now she's in she's
okay she's
because she's the right-hand man type
person yes okay
so if she dies in prison yes if she dies
in prison
then what to suicide do you still think
absolutely
very very suspicious now i'd be like
okay let's start reading some [ __ ]
let's start looking at jizz lane
spelled that's how you actually
pronounce it jizzling
oh man yeah i i just
don't want to live on that road what a
[ __ ] so if she ends up dying in
prison
then that would be absolutely you'll
have to take it yeah i i listen that if
she dies in prison
i'll read everything on [ __ ] epstein
we'll come back and we'll do a four-hour
podcast i'll order
information we'll do the whole thing
yeah we'll get sean atwood in here he's
not allowed here
he's actually on a he's exiled yeah
he'll be on it it'll be a zoom
yeah but yeah we'll get him get a
[ __ ] video screen right there
because i'll be all in you know that
would be pretty [ __ ] sick if we could
actually pull that off
you know we you know what we should do
somebody suggested this the other day
was like uh
you get like jordan belfort
me and somebody else yeah that's trying
to come
and do a uh do like just sit down and
talk for three or four hours just let
you guys
this [ __ ] i think you should get jordan
belfort on the mat cox
true crime podcast because that would be
good absolutely
that would be great you know i actually
talked to his
uh secretary like we shot emails back
and forth back and forth
and um it just never the corona thing
happened next thing you know i mean that
was it it was over i like i didn't
really didn't follow it up because i
realized there's no way i can go out
there
the same thing with um with sean atwood
like i wanted to try and go
to london and after about a month and a
half two months i realized this is an
ending this is gonna be a while so then
i said i sent him an email said look bro
this is not happening
let's just do a pod let's just do the
podcast i mean um let's just do like a
zoom or skype and he was like yeah let's
do it i do them all the time
yeah it was a good one yeah i watched it
you've seen it all before i've seen it
all beforehand
i love listen what's your favorite
podcast you've been on
what i like this one i like just sitting
here talking [ __ ]
yeah you know i mean just you know um
you know who was good was uh
oh god what was it pat david with a
valuetainment mm-hmm
he was he had a very professional thing
going on but he's a very nice
you know nice likable guy and friendly
and uh
that was good but this is more of a
laid-back just talking
about you know just you know you mean
you meant though you mean the actual
channel
no i mean like you're most the best the
like out of all podcasts we've done that
was your favorite to do
not vlad no why not
no he's you know first of all he's not
there he's a he's on a
yeah on another ipad and he's behind
it's behind the scenes did he read your
book
no and he didn't read my book and he
didn't know the story and not just that
but when you're talking i'm really
talking to him the other
the guy the videographer guy who's he's
not really there he's off to the side
i'm talking to vlad vlad whatever once
while he go okay okay he'd ask a
question
and i knew he didn't and he wasn't
paying attention he would get up and go
to do something while i'm talking and
it's like
i want to stop and be like are you
like i'm at my attention right yeah you
know because i feel like this look
it's like if you put the camera in front
of me and said okay just tell your story
to the camera
i'd have a hard time yeah but if danny's
standing behind the camera
i can talk to danny because i'm just
telling danny the story i don't really
see the little boxes being
like the fans or people viewing it it's
just i don't okay it's okay
hey danny here's what happened and i'll
tell danny yeah it just doesn't feel
right it doesn't feel right to me
you know i need an audience yeah just
probably i'm sure has
you know probably some narcissistic
how much more money you got matt going
on over here we are at
we got any good comments any good
questions oh yeah we got a bunch of
questions somebody
wanted to know how much would it be
to get a painting of danny in an
armchair holding a football
do you play armchair quarterback
that's great i love that um
do black shirts make you look taller is
that why you wear them
nice i don't i wear black a lot you know
what the worst thing about this you
understand my girlfriend's probably
watching this
you understand how horrible that is
she's kind of she oh she does she picks
on me like you can't believe it yeah i'm
sure she's like
listen not you know that she does the
whole t-rex thing with my little art
she's like you got these little tiny
lines
at least they're thick arms they're
short thick arms
that's why i don't even do arms here
here's a good here's a good question on
twitter
do you currently know about do you know
about any current fraud with covid loans
going on
and do you have any friends or anyone
that does fraud today
do i have do you know anybody who does
fraud today
this is i don't think you can say yes
and that you're probation enough
that was a great question thank you good
talk
why does he never mention stealing those
two kids identities
stealing those two kids kids yeah what
kids are they which kids
someone said you never mentioned it so
we wouldn't even know i'm not sure what
are they what kids
[Music]
do you ever steal any kids identities um
yeah i used
uh i used initially i used a social
security number a ra
random social security numbers and they
were recently issued
so obviously they did belong to kids
while i was initially trying to figure
out
how the credit profiles worked
so you know yeah you could say you know
you could say that that was a
theft here's a good one how bad is your
current financial situation
and do you think you'll ever be able to
pay off your restitution in full
boy these are [ __ ] serious questions
bro right like people are serious
that's um do i ever think i'm gonna be
able to pay off my
my restitution like how dire is my
financial situation
like i have like a little bit of a
cushion but the code thing has
really jammed me up like i had a i had
paintings probably for two or three
months
and i'm just looking at the bank right
now like i'm not gonna tell you how much
mean my prio knows no i probably have a
couple grand in the bank that's it
and that's really it and then i've i
have rent my rent's like 750
my car payments you know for something i
mean i've got
you know so you start adding up you know
food you know all this other stuff
huh yeah your food your your you know
150 bucks for your
uh car insurance and you start adding it
up it's like jesus
i'm eating i'm living on granola bars
and like pickles and stuff i mean it's
i'm not doing it
what kind of pickles wiggles pickles um
wiggles are the best they're so spicy
and sweet
what what happened to dinner yeah i'm
starving i'll take you out to eat after
this
unbelievable so uh people don't like
people or
at least ordered kfc because
i saw the funniest comment like now i
know why this channel's never gonna know
go anywhere because they were eating
crab
that's the reason that we ate the crab
nails that's why we're going to keep
eating crab
will i ever pay off my resume could have
got a bucket of kfc a lot would have to
go right for me to pay off my
restitution
it's 5.99 down to like 5.9 million and
change
i don't have any interest on it um
that's good yeah it's probably the only
argument that my lawyer
actually won uh during my sentencing
uh would there normally be interest on
that yeah really absolutely what kind of
interest are we talking i don't know i
don't really know i mean i got like
not lucky i mean how lucky could i get
them there you could add the interest
because i'm probably not gonna be able
to pay that either
so you basically you know you'd have to
hit it big to be able to pay that off
bro
a lot would have to go right for me to
pay off pay that off
a lot would have to go right and you
know it's like
so it just it's going to hang over my
head for you know here on out
well you know um at least you got it
interest-free
yeah yeah that's nice so we'll see
what happens let's see what else we got
somebody wanted to know if you would
ever host a seminar
on how to host a seminar
i don't know i'm just reading you what i
don't even know what that means i don't
even know that
i was hoping you could maybe i i i can't
i can't clarify i need money for the
damn paintings
yeah yeah bro someone buy the paint a
painting
someone buy the painting yeah nobody
make it make a reasonable offer
you know what the problem is it's it's
it's
it's your clientele the person is really
upset who sent you the money to sign a
quarter
because they don't think you're going to
send them a quarter well he's not i'm
not they said
i'm a dollar i'm not sending you the
i'm taking your money and i'm gonna i
can't buy anything with it it's not like
even even taking the money is
what can you buy what do they send me
like a dollar a dollar 25
a dollar 35.35 yeah you get stamps
you can't even yeah what am i going to
do with 1.35 if you come picking i mean
the
the effort alone isn't worth a dollar
send the paypal pal the effort alone
isn't worth 1.35 yeah
i mean you know it doesn't it's not
worth it what's it worth what's it worth
what will you sign a quarter and ship it
to him for
i'm i'm what's ten dollars how do you
sign a quarter
somebody get a quarter out and try and
sign it i'd love to see that yeah that
would be pretty difficult
that would be pretty difficult
you know this is my second cup my second
one since i i came in with the one i
finished
it this is almost done you got two
where's your other one
i finished it it's down there put up on
the table so i can see it
with the fan the fact that i would like
i would like fans want to see like i was
like i walked in with two of these
i finished this one basically before we
started you haven't pissed yet
no i'm good wow you gotta [ __ ] i mean
giant bladder i'm an old man
so